Amsterdam is one of the most livable
human-centered cities on the planet
after having dared to move past the
core-centric state of school when I
cycled around the city with not just
bikes I was amazed how convenient it was
and how calm and safe I felt throughout
the trip Amsterdam is a gold standard of
walkability and bike friendly urbanism
that the rest of the world including
Europe more of all that that includes me
living in Germany compared to Amsterdam
and other Dutch cities Germany is a
mixed bag lots of Germans are still
addicted to their cars and cannot
imagine their lives without them while
many others are ready for a change urban
areas in Germany grain shop loud filthy
depressing Urban motorways
to large Transit oriented spaces
from dystopian grimy underpasses
to Friendly pedestrianized promenades
bike and pedestrian friendly
human-centered areas while definitely
there are often patchy and inconsistent
for now anyway compared to the gold
standard of Amsterdam German cities are
still far behind but what if I told you
we are not in Amsterdam this is Leipzig
Germany a city that makes no excuses
when creating truly bike friendly
human-centered spaces
as a rule of thumb a good psychopath is
when you would let your small children
bike on on their own without feeding for
their lives this is why so-called cheros
and bicycle gutters are terrible the
leadership of Leipzig is well aware of
this therefore the city is full of safe
separate bike paths with adjacent
traffic limited to 30 kilometers per
hour
on the back street you don't even need
it designated bike lane traffic is few
and far between and the speed limit is
low time to head in for a Saturday
morning coffee and cake on this com
friendly Street
and while we're sitting here I would
also like to thank Atlas VPN for
sponsoring today's video Atlas VPN
offers a service that encrypts your data
and hide your virtual location from
Brian your eyes it helps you protect
your privacy and allows you to bypass
those ever annoying region locks with
Atlas VPN you'll be able to unlock all
that content locked away from you
arbitrarily only based on your location
like on Netflix and other streaming
platforms all you need to do is open the
app pick a server and that's it Atlas
VPN also includes a breach scanner
function able to tell you if there are
any data leaks associated with a given
email address Atlas VPN also allows you
to block unwanted trackers from websites
with their new tracker blocker feature
all you need to do is flip the switch
currently Atlas VPN is running a huge
discount for their three-year plan for
just 199 dollars per month and of course
with a 30-day money-back guarantee the
link is in the description atlas of
course runs both on desktop and mobile
and is compatible across all well-known
operating systems protect your privacy
and don't let region blocks stop you
take advantage of this discount today by
clicking the link in the description
thank you for checking out Atlas the
ends like this helps support what I do
and now back to the video
after the break it's time to look around
the city
Leipzig has been progressively
reclaiming space from cars and giving it
back to Everyday People it's fun to
stumble upon an Urban Oasis like this in
a place that used to be a Barren asphalt
Wasteland dead tissue in the Heart of
the City
though apparently some people came out
to protest against taking away their
free parking spots in 2019. one of the
signs says we want equal rights this is
very funny when we consider that an
inner city leiptig where this protester
plays only 25 percent of trips are made
by car yet cars dominate the majority of
public space at least they did back when
this protester plays trying to chip away
at this outrageous privilege by turning
an asphalt Wasteland into a social space
and dozens of entitled snowflakes will
come out to scream at you for it
unfortunately for them it's not up to
the silent majority to conform to the
excessive convenience needs of an
out-of-touch loud minority as the saying
goes when you're privileged equality
feels like oppression sorry snowflakes
but in Leipzig your time is coming to an
end the core Centric hard times have
created strong men who are now creating
Good Times which would then create even
more strong men via clean air enough
movement and low noise pollution
biking in Leipzig is simply Pleasant and
at no point have I felt in danger
cyclists are almost always separated
from cars and the motor traffic speeds
are limited for safety areas where this
isn't true are the temporary exception
instead of the Eternal Norm
toxicity in motion it's a popular
college town with a steadily increasing
population currently around 600 000. in
the center there is a whole new bike
friendly walkover residential district
being built on former industrial land
with mixed zoning lots of green spaces
and mid-rises sporting 2100 Apartments
plus schools and kindergartens they
obviously watched my video about why
skyscrapers are a bad idea previously I
talked about shadows and bicycle gutters
being terrible and they are core Zoom
passed right next to you at high speeds
the surface is uneven and they fall at
the wrong time it means getting run over
on this bridge Leipzig solved that
problem by converting one entire traffic
lane on each side to cycling Lanes there
is a need buffer zone between you and
cars making you feel safe this Lane
conversion increases efficiency since a
lane can move up to 12 000 cyclists per
hour compared to only 2 000 cars Leipzig
accomplished this massive Improvement
not through a multi-million Euro
construction project but with a bucket
of yellow paint so Mayors please take
note the Surfers will need some reass
faulting eventually as scores have
created rots all over the place it's
insane how quickly cars destroyed their
own infrastructure and were spending
billions and billions on this every year
when was the last time you saw a bike
lane having to be patched most of us
haven't that's because the heavier the
vehicle the more damage it does to the
road exponentially so case in point an
average car causes road damage 1600
times that of a fat man on a freakishly
heavy bicycle you know the meme about
how Roman Rhodes survived to this day
but then the engineers arrived an hour
full of potholes that's because of cars
not the engineers
foreign
I just wish my bike didn't Creak so much
I left it out in the rain for a few days
I can't record like this what should I
do well I should call a service center
which will schedule me in one month from
now where instead of repairing the
problem Parts they replace my entire
bike frame for 500 euros just kidding my
bike is not a Tesla let's go to a
hardware store which isn't out at the
edge of town next to a highway but right
in the center near the main station
connected by this convenient fully
separated bike path
after a five minute bike ride time to
get some oil bearing grease and that
range that I've been putting off buying
for the last 6 months leaving the
hardware store this bike parking area of
a nearby Office Building looks like a
good spot for a quick repair
just tightening a bolt or two some oil
to the right places and the bike is good
to go no scheduling no wait list no
service fees just some good
old-fashioned do-it-yourself maintenance
let's visit the leiptech Historical
Center because it is beautiful and fully
pedestrianized
there is even an underground s-bond
station with four frequent commuter
lines
just look at this Alleyway and try
telling someone it would look nicer
really terrific Lane any row of parked
cars
another very nice thing about Leipzig is
the abundance of on-street bicycle
parking racks many cities forget these
it's one thing to be able to get
somewhere on a bike but you also need a
convenient civilized way of locking it
lampposts fences and traffic signs don't
count thankfully in Leipzig such
convenient on-site bicycle parking is
ubiquitous they are everywhere
some areas in Leipzig remain very much
core centered the legacy of megalomaniac
Soviet urban planning where in former
East Germany after all speaking of
what's going on over there some sort of
mini protest let's see a Russian flag
the flag of Saxony two peace flags and
two flags of the German Raj
uh wait one sec
there we go my civic duty is done for
the day it's getting dark soon so it's
time to head to the station I'm visiting
a friend in a nearby City
the holy station area is still all their
car Centric there is a safe separated
signaled bike path all the way
Oh look The Old underpass I'm glad
they've canceled it underpasses are just
a way to expel human beings underground
so that cars can rule the surface World
good riddance
our journey ends at Leipzig main station
a huge impressive building
it even has an underground multi-level
Mall integrated into it and it has one
of the most impressive Starbucks coffees
I've ever seen seriously just look at it
Starbucks and German Imperial
architecture are a good mix apparently
my train is departing in a few minutes
so this is where I'll conclude my home
city of Leipzig through conscious
consistent effort is turning itself into
a truly bike friendly livable
human-centered place instead of [ __ ]
Solutions like sherios they actually do
what needs to be done and the city is
better for it as it tailors itself to
the silent majority instead of a loud
entitled minority the amount and
coverage of bike friendly infrastructure
is almost unprecedented in the country
this is why I'm calling Leipzig
Germany's hit in Amsterdam have you been
to German cities that are as bite
friendly as Leipzig let me know in the
comments thank you for watching if you
appreciate my content you can support me
on patreon where I sometimes post
pictures of my cats and I'll be seeing
you all next time